well we know that he's a great comforter
the president because we we saw him with
a group of victims of gun violence this
weekend we saw we were Tonko before when
he talked to the war Widow on the phone
comforting is not his thing he had to
have a crib sheet look at that it's in
his hand they actually wrote look at the
last one
I hear you they had to write on the
bottom of it I hear you for him to be
reminded to say that and we found out
that in the Trump administration
everybody has these crib sheets you know
like notes to self so it's a new
department here it's called notes to
self I'm not going to show you but
everybody write house for example at
Donald Trump jr. a food goes in mouth
Jeff Sessions it's African American not
colored these are things they have to
remind themselves Sarah Huckabee Sanders
has wife beaters equal bad alright Rick
Perry our energy secretary don't call it
electricity
[Applause]
melodia it's so big you're hurting me
yeah
[Applause]
evanka says that refer to Gerardus
husband not co-conspirator it's Jared
find out what two-state solution means
[Laughter]
Sean Hannity don't get any in your hair
Ted Cruz watch what humans do act like
them
[Applause]
and John Kelly unplugged nuclear button
please